it was of course last fall while the nfl
was investigating the washington
football team that some of john gruden's
emails were revealed so it led to his
eventual resignation and in november
gruden filed a lawsuit against the nfl
sports director chris matthews joining
us now as the league responds to that
lawsuit chris yeah denise gruden's
contention is the nfl leaked those
emails to the wall street journal and
new york times and there is a conspiracy
to get him out of the league while the
league was investigating the washington
football team and pouring over 650
thousand emails only gruden's were
revealed this evening the nfl filed a
motion to have the nevada judge dismiss
gruden's case saying those half dozen
emails he sent over a seven year period
were abhorrent but on his own doing
also there is no conspiracy against
gruden the paper is also claiming that
gruden couldn't have the expectation of
privacy the court also asking to stay
the motion until it decides if the case
should move to arbitration under nfl
contracts disputes are mandated to be
settled in arbitration now we'll wait
and see if gruden responds his lawyers
argue that his case belongs before a
judge and not in arbitration one thing
not included in the newly filed
documents is how the wall street journal
or the new york times got gruden's
emails so perhaps we haven't heard the
last of this from the nfl or john
gruden's lawyers on this case we'll have
much more ted